and thanks again for everybody joining
us for another one of the seamen cinemas
in America webinars this one is going to
be on five axis three plus two G code
programming specifically with what we
call cycle 800 or a swivel cycle we've
we've done some previous webinars on
this content around the shop-bell side
of the operating interface this is going
to be LG code based this is going to be
talking about Katie and posted files
some common challenges you might face
when programming externally with plain
biplane to functionality so that's what
we're going to be going through over the
course of the next probably hour or hour
and a half okay I am your host Chris
I am a dealer support specialist on the
East Coast for Siemens and here's my
contact information I'm certainly a
resource for anybody out there if you
have any questions specific to operation
and programming content or want to dig
into a little bit of some of the backend
knowledge of the product
I am certainly always a resource here
for you guys so charlie feel free to
reach out best source ugly email but you
can always try to get me on the phone I
do travel a fair amount so sometimes
it's a little challenging to get cell
reception okay so just to promote a few
more webinars that we have coming up
here and in the July we are going to be
doing a four axis mill centered around
shop mill programming and then in
September we are going to be doing one
on the new DXF reader but this is
specific to software version 4.7 so we
had a previous tool that allows us to do
DXF functionality you had to do that
externally and now in software version
4.7 we've actually embedded it into the
cinematic control directly so we will be
doing a webinar based on that and we'll
continue content beyond this
so today's webinar everything we talked
about will apply to either of our two
platforms here the Cinemark 8:28 control
or the cinematic 8:40 d control so
really any of the functionality we
talked about we utilize will apply
dealer water no matter what environment
you find yourself on or working on so as
I briefly said before the big thing we
want to go through here is starting to
leverage our swivel cycle or our cycle
800 in a g-code environment really
getting you guys up to speed on not only
if I wanted to long hand right at the
control but more importantly how do I
then handle it with externally posted
programs and start to utilize some of
this functionality so we will talk about
some setup functions here in the
beginning we do want to point out a few
features and functions that will help
you with setting up five axis machines
start the directory into knowing where
these offsets are writing to so you can
kind of align them with the method of
programming that you're doing so with
that being said I do want to transition
into the setup side of the control and
specific to five axis so there's a lot
of features and functions here that we
can take advantage of but we do want to
look at some of the key ones when
getting into five accents from moved
from motion from moving the machine
register having any different than a
three axis machine tool one of the
differences you obviously going to have
a few more additional axes so it's going
to be up to the OEM how he wants to lay
it out on the front panel but generally
you're going to see that either the
button set like we see on the right side
of the screen will give you a fourth or
fifth axis option when you get to the
pulse generator your remote hand wheel
it's either going to be some kind of a
radial toggle on the hand wheel or
sometimes they drive it from the screen
if there's no access selectra on the
handle but you'll see that the the
system itself because it's so modular
it'll just add access functionalities to
it so something is basic like the
position screen to move the machinery
well if it's commissioned as a five axis
machine you'll immediately get those
additional axes in the field so if you
wanted to move the machine not only
linear but also drive the rotaries you
can do that right from any of the native
screens you're used to even running the
machine as a simple three or four axis
variant now when we get to setting up a
five axis machine there's a few other
steps that we probably don't think about
when we think about from setting up a
simple 3x machine and I always like to
kind of relate it back to what a lot of
us did back in probably early days of
our career on a manual bridgeport so if
I walk up to a manual Bridgeport what's
usually one of the first steps I want to
make sure that it is accurate probably
the first thing I want to do is just
make sure is the spindle squared on my
table is the machine tram din it's my
head square you know who knows who ran
that the Bridgeport left she could be
kicked at all kinds of crazy angles well
it's the same concept when you get the
five axes I need to set the plane that
I'm going to be working on as my base
plane first so that would be my squaring
up my head process once I've defined
that then I'm going to have to align my
workpiece so that's just like back in
the day on that manual Bridgeport where
I was indicating in that vise as we see
from our nice little animated picture
there on the right so we're going to
want to set that next and then after and
only after those two features have been
set in that sequence we'll then go and
find our part zero if you don't follow
that sequence of events then the data
you're about to set may not be in the
same location so I was to square up the
edge or align the edge of my part but I
never set my tool normal I never
actually told the tool that hey this is
the surface I need to be perpendicular
to well that edge may not actually be
there anymore because my rotor is going
to move so you always want to follow
that process just like I was setting up
that manual machine all those years ago
set your plane then set your edge and
then go and find your zero now certainly
if I don't need to establish the plane
if I'm working with a date and relative
to the machine table then potentially I
could I could skip over that step and go
right to the edge but always think of
that process as you go
so functionally at the control we've
incorporated a bunch of features under
the measure workpiece tool the tool that
we're going to talk about right off the
bat would be your line plane that's how
I set my tool normal that's how I square
up that head to the surface and then my
align edge then from there you can drive
it in and you can set a zero and you can
go from from that point so when you go
to on a line plane most likely you would
probably have a probe in the spindle
could be done manually if you wanted to
but you're really just going to come
down you're going to probe three points
on the surface and that's going to start
to write offsets for you to align that
surface next step this is the same
process with our line edge function now
I'm going to touch two points I see the
align edge in the lower hand corner of
the screen and by coming in datum into
those two points it will then skew or
align that plane or that edge just so
goes our aligning device on that manual
Bridgeport so where do these offsets
start to right how does this
functionality start to work well a
couple ways I can drive offset data in a
multi axis machine I can certainly do
what we call direct axis offset and that
would be writing an offset directly to
my a or my C but there's also a whole
other method of setting up a machine
tool in the Siemens control which is
what we call coordinate rotations
rotations about a linear axis and that's
what I'm seeing in the lower section
under the details of my work coordinate
feel so here you're not actually writing
an offset to the axe of the C axis
directly you're actually defining the
machine and telling it I want to do a
rotation about a linear axis so in our
example here I have 10 degrees 10
degrees is a rotation about my x-axis
five degrees is going to be a rotation
about my Y and then Z is going to be 30
degrees about the Z so what the system
will automatically do is it will then
take these values and then calculate it
out what the resulting motion would need
to be for the table to get to the right
location now depending on the cycle you
start to use will depend on where it's
going to write this data or how you
write the data that to it
so we take a look at Cindy trained here
I have a basic five axis machines set up
and we want to start to take a look at
the offset tables or or these measuring
function so I say I go to my measure
workpiece field and I'm going to get a
selection of different measuring cycles
up so if I first look at my align plane
I start to see that it's asking me to
start to touch off different points now
initially it's going to use whatever I
happen to have in the spindle so I would
probably want to have a tool change to a
probe so I'm just going to stick a probe
in the spindle here real quick and we
can kind of simulate what the process
would be to actually align this but more
importantly I want you start to get your
head around where the offsets are going
so what you're going to do is you're
going to go over to the align plane I'm
going to jog the machine to a first
measured location once it's there I'm
going to implicit cycle start she's
going to feed down and Z until it
measures that point now it's asking me
to just to move to some other random
point on that surface so in my case
maybe I'm going to move my Y over a
little bit
IBM a Z to some slight new location so I
get a little different measurement touch
that surface now I'm going to move to
some other location and do one more
touch I'm a little close to the over
travel where she was sitting
okay so the system recorded threes three
points it hasn't done anything with it
yet it's up to me to tell it to write to
the work chord and it's going to write
to whatever work coordinate I've
selected so right now we have g54
selected now we see we have no other
options as to the type of alignment or
type of measurement she's going to take
so the minute I set this set were
Cornette what it did was it now wrote to
these coordinate rotation fields that I
was just explaining it does give me the
option of driving the Machine normal to
that position I'm not going to worry
about moving it yet so nothing's
physically moved my rotaries is still at
zero but if I look at my offsets I go
over to my work offset we now get a
little rotational symbol in the work
corner level now I have values in a or
see there's still zero
down but what I did get is that they go
into the details of the work coordinate
just by hitting the details button while
I'm highlighting on the work coordinate
I will start to see that the Machine
started to calculate in position some
data some coordinate rotations now I was
obviously just arbitrarily jogging
machine around you're going to start to
realistically get some small incremental
values here maybe I got a little bit of
a tip in my x-axis or my Y so this is
what we call a coordinate rotation
alignment this method is going to be
used when you get into what we call
kinematic independent programming which
we're going to talk about quite a bit in
a few minutes here in this content if
you're driving programs from a cam
system and the cams on direct axis you
want to be very careful that you don't
do coordinate rotation setups because
you can run into depending on how the
machines commissioned you could run into
inconsistencies so I always come an
advocate of training people as they get
onto these machines keep your process
consistent if you want to use coordinate
rotations do everything with coordinate
rotations now this is more important I'm
just going to get rid of this all set
for now we don't need it this is more
important when you get to the align edge
function because in the align edge
function it's possible for a builder to
set up this function to allow you to
write directly to your axis so when you
get to a line edge you're probably going
to get some options now I can do a
coordinate rotation and this would write
to the corresponding axis if I was just
sitting simply a square to my table and
and I found two points it would write to
a rotation about my Z but I can also
drive it directly to the a or the z axis
so what you want to be careful of is you
want to give you couple getting a mixed
bag I don't want to do a plane rotation
that's going to write to my coordinate
rotations and then go do an alignment
it's going to write to my direct axis
because these offsets can start fighting
each other you want to keep it
consistent in either method and
generally I will try to align it to the
method of programming I'm using once I
get to my part programs
okay so as we start to apply these
values the next thing you're going to
want to do is now try to anticipate this
motion when I start to move the Machine
around so so for argument's sake here
we're showing you a basic rotation that
may have been applied around my z-axis
so what will happen is first thing as
things start to spin around
I might not actually stable move you
know let's say for argument's sake I'm
in a machine that has two rotaries up in
the head well the part can't spin the
part can't move so as I start to apply
these rotations what it's doing is its
rotating your coordinate system so
machine has the capability of moving
relative to that and if I do any
commanded move and the values and the
offset it will will always track
relative to the values that are sitting
in my work offset however any of the
jogging it's important to pay note to
this because there's actually two
different ways to tell the Machine how
you want a job you can tell it that when
I move the axes it's going to move
always relative to the Machine
coordinate system or we have the ability
saying hey take into account the values
that are in the offset and move relative
to those values and that's where this
little WCS MCs button comes into play
and this is very important especially
when you get on a machine that has mixed
kinematics or head-head kinematics and
you want to be able to move relative to
this new orientation that's new plane so
how does this work will show you real
quick so whatever offsets happen to be
active I'm just going to force a quick
little offset let's assume that we went
in and we found a couple edge points and
it wrote in and wrote some value and
I'll just throw 45 degrees in here wrote
some value as a rotation about my z-axis
so nothing spun just because there's a
value here it didn't in AC axis rotary
everything's still sitting zero but the
coordinate system spun so if I was to
jog the machine in x-axis right now and
not do anything special I'm looking at
my display right and I start to move the
machine lizards crank them I override
see how I see two numbers moving now the
machine's not actually tracking with two
axes spinning in fact if I were to
display my actual machine values which
is showing me what my physical motors
are doing a jhaggat I only see the
x-axis move but since the work
coordinate system is now rotated about
the Z as I jog I'm getting further away
or closer to that plane in two axes so
this is where the WCS MCS button comes
in let's say you wanted to throw an
indicator in the spindle you want to
indicate across that edge and track that
edge well by saying to the system hey I
want you to jog now relative to whatever
values are in the work coordinate system
by putting this light on and then
picking an axis now as I'm displaying
the work or net system if I jog the
Machine I only see one number changing
but if you physically look at your
actual machine values then we started
jog it we see we get to servos tracking
so what where I like to use this a lot
is you know I may come on I may go in I
may align to a plane it may rotate my
coordinate system around it some funny
angle and the first step is I may not
know which direction x and y really are
in anymore because they've been rotated
around some orientation so the first
thing I do is get yourself oriented so
if I need the job my axe or if I command
X to move what direction is it going in
it's going to be probably skewed at some
angle the next question is what is plus
among what is minus right I could spawn
all the way around so where plus or
minus appear to be back where it is
relative to the G coordinate system this
gets important when you start to use
your measure workpiece functions you
know maybe I wanted to align to a couple
holes right I'm going to date on one
datum - well if I don't know which
direction X plus and X - is in I might
start the wrong location or she might go
moving to the wrong direction so you
want to get yourself kind of orientated
to this rotation as we start to spend
things around especially because
remember you have full freedom full
Ranger mode
year we position the coordinate system
anywhere you want so these are some of
the tricks you're going to start to do
but really all this functionality is
really all just getting used to these
cycles that are available and then where
they're writing the data to and again
they're writing the data directly to the
work offset you can see this detail
button either in the active field or if
you look at all your work coordinates
you always get a detail and so I'm just
going to give you the details of
whatever work coordinate you have
highlighted so let's say I'm on 56 I had
details I don't have any values in this
one specifically so everything's at zero
however if I go to work coordinate 154
now I see where we had some numbers
displayed okay
so what we're going to do is our next
step is we're going to actually get into
starting to look at the program in more
detail and some of these features and
functions I want to just give you guys a
little more of a detailed description if
you refer back to the shop mil webinar
as well I did go through a lot of this
setup stuff for five axes in some detail
as well so you can always refer back to
that one okay so now we're in jog we're
applying these offsets we're moving the
machine around I'm probably going to
want to be able to then swing the table
normal to this surface because I'm going
to want to continue to move in the
operation sense so let's say we were to
have you know aligned our plane we touch
three points but I won't want to now
move so my physical tool is squared of
that surface whether it's my spindle
tipping over because I have a head head
kinematic or it's the trunnion swinging
or some combination thereof I need to
have a way of driving the machine to
location and then letting it present
that surface without having to try to
crank it over or jog or command each
axis that's where it comes into us
having embedded a simplified version of
cycle 800 or the Swivl cycle which we're
going to be using in programming and we
put it here in jog for us to use as part
of your setup process so that's what
you're seeing here so in the jog screen
the lower right-hand corner we have the
swivel function
and what we did was we probably came in
aligned to some service and then I want
to go normal to that surface so I can
start to drive the machine to this
location now this swivel cycle is going
to come very handy not only for
presenting the services from setup
feature but also maybe I need to cancel
a rotation because I had to shut the
Machine off halfway through a machining
process and my rotary czar contorted at
some position so what you're going to do
is you're going to use the swivel
feature that we see wrote right here in
conjunction with this alignment so let's
say like we were playing around with
before we went through and we have
aligned three points so let's say for
argument's sake in our coordinate it
ended up that it calculated a 10 degree
rotating around X and a negative 3
degree around Y okay so I would have
probed the three points those values
would be there but the Machine hasn't
moved yet
and I don't really know where it's going
to move to make that surface normal well
that's where the swivel cycle comes in
so in the swivel cycle I can first
enable what we call our tool carrier or
a swivel name this is what's loading all
the offsets in the backend that's
managing the kinematics of the machine I
can tell it hey I want to get the head
up into a safe spot get it out of the
way we're going to go through all these
features again in the programming area
and then I can drive the machine to some
rotation but if I do in an initial 0 and
I just tell to do a read track and
everything that's zero what it's going
to do she's going to move to this
position relative to whatever work
coordinates loaded and it will use the
offsets so now I see the Machine moved
through negative ten point four three
six and it calculated a rotation of one
hundred and sixty degrees well it
calculated this value based on the
measurement I had taken or the offsets
that are written right here so if you're
doing the process just like we talked
about earlier and you know I aligned
might spend a little on my head to the
table and then I want to align my edge
or my datum surface well I would need to
present that surface first right I want
to I want to
make it square I don't want to have that
surface at some weird angle when I try
to measure the X or the edge of it same
thing here so this is where you're going
to use it through your process when I'm
when I'm doing my setup I'll measure my
plane I'll come in
I'll driver normal to that surface then
maybe we'll square up so so maybe it
went and it took a measurement and it
found that it had to apply a little
offset in the z-axis of I don't know 15
degrees just to throw some numbers at it
well to make that one active I just come
back to the swivel cycle recycle start
machine now moved to some other rotation
and now we're aligned and then I can go
in and I can set my zero and certainly
set my zero would be the same as I would
do on any machine I could do a basic
edge kick we could come in and we could
sorry we can maybe find the center of a
feed sugar- center of a hole and how are
you going to do that process now the
other thing I mentioned was what happens
if I was moving the Machine around so
let's say for argument's sake
it was jogged at some reported position
wherever happens to be and I want a
driver back to zero to machine zero
that's another area where I can use a
swivel cycle so I can shut the program
off come out to swivel let it do a
safety retract until it initial now
remember it's going to use whatever's in
the work coordinate so in this case it's
not going to drive all the way to zero
just the compensated value that offset
however if I don't want any offset
values as long as I have zero in YZ
it'll also allow me to drive the machine
back to machine zero so now everything
goes back to zero machines in place and
the final thing I like to use the Solo
mask for is canceling of the Swivl cycle
so whenever the Swivl cycles on you get
this little indication right here that
the carrier name is loaded any of those
little green boxes as is active that
means that there's offsets in play that
are tracking or moving the machine
or affecting the promotion in fact if
you were to go to your offset table and
look at your active offsets it starts to
show you some of these offset values
that are starting to come into into into
effect as I'm with the Machine around
well if you want to just cancel all
active offsets come in here select as a
zero cycle start that will also cancel
the Swivl cycle record so you're going
to use it for this couple things
certainly aligning during the process of
setup for obviously you know sending her
back to a save location when I'm done
like maybe I shut her off in the middle
of a cycle and then canceling the record
now additionally I have a couple
different options here to cancel the
record probably the next the most common
would just be just doing a simple MDI
and what you'll see in a lot of your
g-code programs especially if they're
posted out you're going to see a simple
cycle a 100 open close parenthesis that
would do the same thing as what we just
did with the Swivl cycle toggling it to
zero that would physically cancel the
tool name or tool carrier and all the
office associated with it and then I
would expect to see go blank all right
ok so from here let's move on to the
programming section of the control and
we want to start to talk about the Swivl
cycle and a little bit more detail here
so first and foremost this is going to
be the basic program that we're going to
go through and talk about having method
eyes this part will pop this up again a
little bit before we start writing the
program but initially let's talk about
the cycle 800 of the Swivl cycle so the
function itself supports two different
types of features so you can do plain
rotation or plain orientation and what
that's going to do is that's going to
allow me to basically present a surface
and make that surface perpendicular to
spindle so when I'm also hadn't done the
XYZ coordinate system of UCS your unit
coordinate system will be aligned to
that surface and Z will be perpendicular
the server's 9% on the flip side I also
can do what's called tool orientation so
that would allow me to tip or angle the
tool relative to a surface but the work
coordinate system stays aligned to where
it was originally on the part it's not
moving the Z so for argument's sake
we're machining a free-form service and
we wanted to skip the tool 30 degrees
but just tip the tool the work horn
system is going to stay where it was
originally you can use this in this
align tool functionality
now this webinar we're specifically
talking about plane rotation so the
feature on the left I would say the
feature on the right it can be used on
standard machines more commonly I see it
used in five axes lathes with the axes
that's where it's really handy because
it allows me to you know take my tool
orientation my turning tool set it off
set to a surface and you can start to
drive it around without it affecting the
work coordinate system could be used on
a mill I've certainly done it with
machining like freeform surfaces but
we're going to concentrate on the one on
the left so what what is it doing you
know as I was just stating it's
establishing a plane and it's moving the
work coordinate system that unit
coordinate system to that new surface
and then making the XY and most
importantly Z align to the machine
spindle now the results of motions
obviously going to change or vary from
machine to machine type but the mask the
cycle is a constant and that's what's
really nice about this so no matter what
type of machine we put this on you're
going to use the exact same setup every
time in the programming environment you
don't have to learn different types of
swivel cycle for different types of
machine kinematics
so what would I see in resulting motion
and probably move our two most common
types of machine a swiveling table which
would be a trending style table or
swiveling head well again for that same
exact interface screen I get two
different motions entirely one's going
to physically rotate the tool tipping
over the other one's going to rotate the
part but it's the same cycle that's
driving both of these behaviors so how
does it work well first step it allows
me to slide or move my coordinate system
the second step it's going to let me
rotate and in my third step it'll
actually allow me to shift the
coordinate system one extra time so if
you noticed in this will animate an
element on the left here we actually
took our zero we slid it to some point
we rotated and then we slid it to a new
location and that's establishing a new
zero so a new zero not only in a
orientation and angular orientation but
in a new linear position too well that's
going to be handled inside of the cycle
800 and then a few extra things that
you'll see so just to kind of reaffirm
it so this is four of your most common
types of kinematics you can see in a 5
axis machine first one to our left is
going to be a head head to assess the
rotaries up in the spindle the part
would stay fixed we have a mixed
kinematic so I have a rotary up and my
spindle and another rotary down on my
table you have a table table kinematic
and that's where both rotor ribs are
down on the table this could be a b c AC
couple different ways and then you get
into what's called newt ated rotary axes
and that's where the table or the rotary
isn't actually perpendicular to the
linear axes are at some kind of angle
you can see that actually here with this
mixed kinematic this is a new tative
axis because see how the a itself is
sitting what looks like a 45 grain so
the swivel side will support any of
these types of kinematics now there's a
few different ways to drive the data to
the civil cycle you can do what we call
kinematic independent programming
the two methods they're practicing was
popular would be accessed by access or
projected angles and then you can also
do what's called direct access
programming that's what's called
kinematic dependent now what do I mean
by kinematic independent or dependent
well basically if I'm writing a program
is there's something in that program
that will only allow it to run on that
specific machine type so the minute I
call out the rotaries so the machine
we're on actually happens to be an AC
rotary configuration well the minute I
actually write a program using the a
this will only ever run on a machine
with an AC rotary configuration it won't
run on a B C it won't run on a mix
kinematic so what you did was you wrote
the program kinematically dependent it
has to have those axes for direct in
kinematic independent programming like
we see on the left for access by axis
axis by axis is just describing a
rotation about a linear axis well every
machine has XY and Z the linear axes
roads there so when you write a program
with kinematic independent programming
it now allows you to move that program
to any type of five axes machine without
any editing required or minimal editing
at that so that's what we're going to
talk about in detail here is we're going
to talk about be accessed by axis method
but will also refer back to direct axis
a little bit okay so when you start to
write special cinematic independent you
are allowing the machine to make some
choices on its own so a lot of times
when I'm doing a rotation if I have
enough travel I can actually have two
different options or scenarios to get to
the same location so I see I have
alternate one or the a tips towards me
or alternate to the a tips away from me
so assuming the machine has enough
travel to get to both scenarios that
would just be a limitation of the sheen
of it but not we have two options so in
the cycle you can drive which solution
is going to use by indirection field
so that's going to allow you if for some
reason there were two scenarios and the
machine chose an undesirable orientation
you can drive that from the swivel cycle
as well when you get to direct access
position there's only one result because
there's only one location so then you
don't have to worry about that in effect
there is no direction option when a
direct axis solution is chosen so we're
going to come in we're going to create a
new program we are going to create a G
code base program and we're going to
build a simple program based on this job
now one of the first things we're going
to talk about is the safety lines and
this is very important because this is
going to set up basically how the rest
of the program is going to start to
respond and we want to make sure that we
start to do this initialization no
matter how the program's coming to us so
whether it was created in a CAD cam
system and be brought over or you're
programming along hand to control so
really these first four lines you see
here I want to see everybody make this
as a standard process so we're going to
basically orient the tool get everything
up to a safe position and square up
everything based on a cycle 800 we're
then going to cancel set going hunter
because we're not sure if we're going to
be using it or not at this point in the
program we're going to add our simple
safety line and a most important we're
going to have our work order called up
here and then we're going to set up our
work fees blank now the workpiece blank
isn't mandatory this is going to help us
for simulation but if you don't do this
step in this process then a bunch of
things could potentially happen for
argument's sake if I threw the workpiece
blank up as the first line of the
program and it was before the work
coordinate as before any cycling hundred
orientation and I had some active
offsets different than the part program
well they can your workpiece into some
position and it's off in space and you
think that there's something wrong well
it's really doing what you told it to do
which is setup the workpiece but
wherever the machine happened to be
sitting or was mortally sitting so this
process will keep from that happening it
will also make sure that the heads in a
safe location the table squared up and
just give you it get you ready for four
going for moving forward into your part
programming from there we're then going
to start to move things around so here
we're just showing you I wanted to give
you a little bit more of a visual of
where the coordinate system is going to
be when we start this program so in our
case we're going to say that the lower
left-hand corner was zero zero and if I
look at a rotational standpoint
everything at initial would be parallel
to the bottom of the part which would be
parallel to the platter on the machine
and nothing's going to be rotated so
that's really what that first sight
gladder is going to do is it's going to
allow me to kind of square up make sure
everything's straight and then we'll
cancel it
we'll start our safety line and move
from there then we're going to start to
use the cycle 800 to start to drive
around this motion so we'll talk about
the table names we'll talk about some
different retraction strategies and then
how do I move my zero around how do I
apply some rotations from there we then
have to start to shift things so I'm
going to start to move around my unicorn
at system my UCS driven by cycle 100 so
in this case this will example we
shifted the 0 over 50 millimeters so
it's entered the 0 on the part and then
we applied a rotation back clicked on
that rotation around the x-axis not
degrees and the negative now what did
that do on this machine well that did a
rotation about a had I been on a machine
that was a BC machine will automatically
spin the platter in degrees and then tip
it around B because it understands there
is no way access so when you're part
programming you don't really have to
worry yourself so much about whether the
rotors are what our motors are there
available for me next operation is going
to be cut some 45s on the part so then
we're going to set the work order system
at an angle 45 little rotation about Y
and then we'll maybe move my zero around
in space so we're going to go through
that then we'll get a chance to start to
run the tool path we'll do a little
simulation and what I have here in this
machine
this machine is actually set up for
collision avoidance so it gives me a
machine space model so you'll be able to
start to see the trend you move around
to and then give you a much better
visual as to what's really happening ok
let's start to write a program now I'm
going to bring up a print here for us
just so you can kind of keep it in the
corner and we'll start to build this
basic program for it alright so so what
what we have here is to keep us from
having to go through the entire thing
and give us a little bit time because
there's a lot of content here I'm going
to grab on program and drop it up here
and we'll use this as our example ok so
first things first when you're going to
start to build your program or setup you
have to know where cycling heart exists
how do I get to the segue heart function
so when you're editing a program or
creating a program first thing you're
going to do is go into the various
button and that's going to give you the
swivel plane feature swivel plane is the
cycle hunter the swivel cycle map so if
you want to get in to that cycle just
hit various it swivel plane and it can
pop you up the mask now the first thing
you're going to do is you're going to
come in you're gonna hit swivel plane
and you're going to hit this initial
button initial settings an initial
setting is going to set it up to a
default solution as because you're out
everything for you so you just want to
kind of come over it and make sure that
this is exactly what you want so first
the thing I'm going to want to do this
is the start of my program I'm going to
want to make sure that I send the head
in someplace safe so that's what's
called your retracts strategy so if the
values that I know then the machine is
not going to move at all so we have a
couple of recharge strategies and
depending on the way the machine is
commissioned by the builder there are
some more or less you'll see here this
one happens to be commissioned where it
allows you to do a straight Z retract
that will move the Z to the extent of
its travel in a plus direction you can
do what's called a maximum tool
Direction retract that would move the
tool out at whatever
angles that until it over travels but
not letting it fully over travel or you
can do an incremental retract and that
would just be a small incremental move
up away from wherever the machine was
sitting so from a safety standpoint
you're going to want to do a full
retract up then you're going to want to
make sure all the values are at zero now
you're probably not going to know what
the directions solution you would
normally want would be yet so we're
going to leave it at its default and
then I'm not gonna want to use tracking
in this case I'm going to do not track
you fill out the page you hit accept
it's going to build this first event for
you now like I said before the next step
in the program is going to then be
canceling of cycle 800 so there's two
ways you could do that if you're at the
Machine and just adding a cycle real
quick if you go to various again and you
go to swivel plane I can select the
swivel record or our tool carrier like
we like to call it under the TC field
but I'd also select a zero so a zero
here hitting accept will build the full
cycle but really it's looking at this
name the second variable to the right if
it sees the name record it's going to
load all those all those offsets all
those parameters in the back end if it
sees a zero it's going to cancel it so
this line would be the same as also
doing a cycle 800 open close parenthesis
I would say from a posted program
perspective more likely than not I'm
going to see the cycle 800 with the open
close parenthesis slighty for a post
developer to type in if i'm longhand
programming at the control a lot easier
to just go to swivel plane pick a zero
and accept it so if six and one half
dozen or the other you can certainly use
either one I'm going to get rid of that
then I want to set up my safety line so
typically I would probably set a tool
plane or tool orientation of g17 load
whatever work coordinate I'm going to be
using so I want to be an absolute
incremental mode and then what's my unit
of measure inch or metric this program
happened to be method eyes din metric
now you want to set up your workpiece
blank
so the workpiece blank is going to set
up the stock so that's going to set up
the blob for us now depending on your
machine commissioning it may or may not
have this clamping field some of the
older software we only introduce the
clamping field in four five so you
wouldn't have seen it earlier some
builders don't put it at all if the
machine is commissioned recording though
you do want to make sure that you set
this and you set this relative to
whatever the orientation of the part is
for your rotaries if you neglect to set
this and you leave it a table then it's
not going to show you five access
simulation when you get to the
simulation screen it's only going to
show you three axes so it's going to
look certainly strange so if I'm doing a
basic basic c-axis clamping where my a
would be at zero my platter would be
squared on my table I would pick a C
axis orientation and then you just
define your blocking and what a basic
size of the block no different than any
other program we've ever done in shop
miller and g code and say except now we
set up certainly a tool i grabbed a
twenty mill cutter that was in the tool
page loaded my offset did a tool change
set up some speeds and some beads maybe
coolant however i'm going to drive it
and now it's time to start doing some
tool right so everything's square
nothing's really happens just put a tool
in the spindle so your first step then
is to now present the first surface we
want a machine so if you look at your
part print we need to machine a ninety
degree angle down this face so to do
that remember my my zero is this lower
left-hand corner and it's right on the
top so it's straight so to do that what
i'm going to do is i'm going to now
create a swivel cycle i want to make
sure that i'm calling up the tool
carrier probably get the head to some
safe spot it's already up there so i can
leave it there and now i can start to
move the machine around so in this case
it is decided to shift the x over so
what will happen is this first motion
this first move this is a linear shift
of your XYZ zero
so what you want to do is you want to
make sure that the X Y Z 0 is on the
corner that you're rotating about in
systems will typically do that that's
okay when you're longhand programming so
it makes a lot easier if at the end of
the day your zero is on the surface that
you're rotated on an established plane
makes you have to do less math so here
we were just shifting the zero to Center
it I'm not doing any shift in X or Y and
now I'm choosing the strategy the option
of how I want to rotate the court the
physical machine how do I want to give
it the information to tell it what I'm
going to do to rotate so we can do
access by axis we can do projected
angles or we can do direct axis but
again this is what we call all kinematic
dependent so once I do this method first
I have to think a lot warm because I
have to kind of track where I need to
present my icy platter but additionally
this will only remember it on an AC
machine so what we're going to do is
we're going to access by axis now I only
really have to think about well what
axis am i rotating about well if I want
to tip it to come down the surface I'm
rotating about the x axis so once I know
I want to just choose my sequence of
events because when you start to do axis
by axis rotation there's an order of
dependency so if I had a value in both x
y&z and they're different numbers and I
tell it I want to do an XYZ solution or
a ZYX solution the result will be
totally different so you do have to
think about as I'm applying rotations
which should happen first if there's
only one rotation it makes no difference
how you set up the sequence it'll always
go to the same position but the minute
you have some kind of compound rotation
then you want to think about it so I
always like to get guys in the habit of
picking the axis they would want to
rotate about first this case X tell it
the angle of rotation here we're going
to do negative 9 degrees because I'm
tipping it down I'm not doing any
rotations in my Y or my Z so I can't
leave them blank or leaving
zero and then do I want to shift the
zero now relative to this new plane so
how do I want to slide the zero down
this this angled surface here right well
then I could do that
so later we're going to set the zero to
the center of the part we can choose the
tracking method which way we want this
thing to tip and then do we want to have
the tool follow the move well if I'm all
the way up at Z zero right I retract the
Machine all the way to the extent of its
travel I don't need to do tracking if
actually by try to tracking I'll
probably get an over travel alarm so we
method eyes the part a little bit so we
can look at a little later with tracking
that's if you know I have a lot of
travels I'm a machine or method eyes a
real nice looking demo let's say then
we'll start to use tracking tracking
does require the machine to be
commissioned with tray or e tray areas
our five axis full sight simultaneous or
dynamic tool path function so if you're
on a machine like an 8:28 it doesn't
support Traer e you won't even get the
tracking option or if your machine
doesn't have you may not get this
tracking option ok so you fill out the
page you save it and then you just
really apply some tool path so in our
case we were just going to face off this
part so I used a basic mill and a basic
face mill cycle so the cycle itself will
then come in and allow me to define some
parameters and I move on so had I put a
quick little m30 here if I was to go
simulate this will now see that the
machine is just going machine that first
surface so there is our 9 degree surface
then it pulls out and it's done what
would the motion look like well if I was
to to run this I would see it tip the a
axis and then the part so from there as
you start to move around or method eyes
these types of programs it's going to be
a lot of the same sequencer events so
the next thing would be well what else
do I want to cut with this facing tool
so maybe I want to take these two 45s
off each corner so now I have to shift
my unicorn system to some point that's
relative to the surface so when I'm
looking at the swivel cycle and as we're
coming down
certainly it asks for my plane that's
going to stay my standard g17 that they
don't normally would tool carry we would
always want to turn on probably a
retract strategy and we have this option
called new or additive so the way this
works is generally I always try to use
new but think of this like the
difference between incremental or
absolute positioning a new rotation will
always revert back to wherever the zero
point is forged 54 an additive rotation
will build on the last rotation so
remember the machine is currently
sitting at a 9 degree tip well I don't
need that 90 degree tip anymore or
because if I look at the print these
corners are parallel to the bottom well
by doing a new it automatically cancels
those rotations if you want to think of
it in your own head as the table is
going to go back straight before it does
that rotation that might be clearer it
won't actually send the table straight
it will go right to this new rotation
but this is going to keep you from
having to unwind anything right tip
anything back
so from there I then really just
position my zero so since my zero back
at this corner I then want to rotate now
remember earlier I said you want to have
the zero somewhere on the surface that's
about to rotate on so if I didn't if I
rotate it right here in this corner and
tip to around 45 degrees well now I'd
have to calculate how far down this
surface is from that point because that
would become my zero but on my print and
I know that this lower edge is 30 mil
down so prior to rotating in this case
if I shift my z thirty millimeters down
I can then do a rotation about Y
negative 45 degrees that's going to tip
so my Z is now perpendicular to this
surface
I don't need to do any other shifts so
then I just save it and now we use a
phasing cycle to handle that so now I'm
going to tell it the basic parameters
and my X so we gave it about 43
millimeter right here to work up a side
the length of the part for design angle
100 millimeters a step-over amount
depakote now in this case my Z 0 is the
finished surface so all of my stock is
in a plus direction so that's why I have
a positive value here in Z zero so when
I get to physically get it to zero
let's tell me right here I will be on
that surface and then just going to kind
of repeat the process so if I want on a
machine this other 45 I come in I'm
going to now slide my zero over to the
other side and X now there's no sequence
or order of operations in the linear
slide it's always going to get to the
same point so you don't have to worry
about any of that I'm not shifting my Y
but I am shifting my Z down that's going
to put me down to this corner then I'm
going to do another 45 but now this is
going to be the opposite direction so
this is a positive 45 around my Y so the
only other thing that I have to think
about is when I did the facing cycle
since my zero is on the right side of
the feature not on the left side of the
feature now my X is in a negative
direction so the only thing that has to
change between the two so from here if
we put a quick m30
and we look at it we now have our three
surfaces machined out so there's the
nine degree plane
then she's going to tip over and doing
that left side negative 45 now I get the
right side now certainly if maybe this
was too aggressive a cut I can move my
z0 my starting gave them up a little bit
we had put positive ten mil I would want
to be more important more attention to
that if I was really going to cut this
part certainly and then you can continue
on now in this case we're going to come
in we're going to we're doing the pocket
with the same tool that we had for the
other planes so now we're going to get
back to our 90 degree plane position is
zero the center but in this case we have
one extra step we're going to do so if
we look at the dimensioning of the
pocket and roll as a surface it's fifty
millimeters down but it's down this
surface so for me to get there I want to
shift my zero after the rotation so now
when I get to the pocket I simply only
have to give it an X 0 I 0 and it'll
machine the pocket at the center of
feature now could I have not slid to
zero down and then put the positive 15
mil right here in the Y absolutely kind
of a six of one half dozen the other
this is really handy if I'm going to be
calling up sub programs that are written
from a specific zero location well now I
don't have to try to manipulate them I
can allow the cycle to establish the new
0 and then just call this up and they
can do that common feature again once
we're all said and done here we're going
to put a little chamfer on the edge of
the part so this is a final now in this
case we used an additive so our zero was
right here alright and now we want to
come down and we want to do a final
rotation around this corner well this is
a good example where an additive becomes
helpful so by choosing additive I can
just do an additional shift down the
plane this case the math calculated out
51 point one degree one millimeters and
now since the four
five is actually relative to the face
then I can tell it to do a 45 degree
rotation and it's actually 45 plus the
nine had I not done an additive then I
would have to take into account the nine
degrees additionally so we do the
additive we did a couple simple feed
moves to drive over to the chamfer now
before you get the tool changes however
this is an area you always want to think
about a little more detail and a lot of
it depends on is the tool change
dependent on whether or not this
rotation is active so what do I mean by
that well we're in a head head machine
so my tool is physically tipped at some
angle and now I'm going to go drive it
up to a tool change well it needs to
straighten that tool out prior to doing
the tool change I would hope that the
tool change marker will handle that but
I don't like to leave things that I can
control in other people's hands so I
would generally make it a good rule of
practice to at the end of the day prior
to my this is actually wrong glad I
looked at it prior to my tool change I
would want to square everything up
Center to zero that puts us in a safe
location then drive the Machine through
tool change now in this case it's
squared back up I want to make sure I
represent my orientation I'll look like
that had gotten moved so let me go back
and rabb cut copy basis of your approval
thing so this should be our nine degrees
yes it is oh it's probably this one is
this my zero is the center yep so let's
copy that place that right here
so I reset my orientation that's going
to position me back to the center of the
feature for my bolt hole pattern then we
just use a standard drilling cycle like
you guys have seen plenty of times
before and other webinars set the
location so I'm going to use a bolt hole
pattern cancel it now at the end of the
program just like at the beginning I'm a
big advocate for send the Machine back
to its safe locations Erie track send
everything back to zero is that initial
function and then cancel the Swivl cycle
when you're done so at the dent end of
the day at the end of the program we're
going to get a method is complete part
you
and there we go now what if we wanted to
play around the tracking what if we
wanted to kind of see what that's going
to do so right now if I was to look at
this part and we were to run it in Auto
now we haven't a feature in here under
simultaneous record where I can bring up
machines in this model so this is the
kinematic of the machine this is the
type of machine we are on right now so
this would be a trunnion style gantry
alright so I have an a so I have an a
rotary I can move that around we can jog
it around a little bit and then we have
a C rotary that spins around you can
kind of see the platter spinning little
hard to see without anything on it ok so
we want to we want to run this rather on
this part so I'm just going to turn off
collision avoidance our good IRA guys
are off to worry about it
so by running the program we'll start to
see what the actual motion would look
like so here machine's going to machine
down the surface tip the table so again
for those wise right when I need to the
rotation about about why it automatic
spot on the platter the desired rotation
represent a dead surface now let's say
for argument's sake I didn't want it to
tip back I wanted to forward for some
reason maybe I had the potential of a
collision maybe there was a clearance
issue at a big fixture up here that's
where that plus or minus scenario comes
into play so had I chose a positive as
opposed to a negative and we looked at
it
now when it goes to this 45 watch where
the table goes in there tip the other
way so that's what that plus or minus
strategy comes into and again assuming
the machine has the travel to get there
this one obviously can rotate the full
the full amount either direction in my a
axis now if I want to look at what the
tracking function would look at right
now every time I'm going to slower down
a little bit so you can kind of see it
all right every time the machine goes to
do a rotary move it's bringing the head
all the way up to machine zero rotates
the axis brings it up rotates the axis
certainly there can be some lost time
there especially if I had a very large
very large machine with a lot of travel
well if you have the tracking function
and you're not doing a tool change
that's an area where I can get to a
clearance point and then follow the
track position so if you look at the
next program we have set up here now
with tracking now the difference here is
when I got to a second or third rotation
I use the track function so there's two
things I did one I didn't use a retract
over to see anymore
I use what's called an incremental tool
retract so that's just saying wherever
you're sitting I want to back up some
amount this case I back to ten
millimeters and then I said okay now I
want you to track so you see on our
little animated element how the tool is
following the rotation so that's a
dynamic move so simply by changing my
track strategy and adding my tracking
function to it now if you watch the
program you'll see how the machine will
start to track around in those positions
so here's our first 9 degrees so there
see how the tools stayed down low to the
part that you do want to watch with the
tracking because you could potentially
end up in a solution where the tool is
lower than that surface but that's the
way the tracking will start to apply for
us and I can see if I can slope without
a little bit more it's hard and harden
easy to get the speed down such products
local development
there you go I see a little bit so see
how it was down when it did that 9
degree rotation
you will feed over let's slow it down
they start to see it
she's going to come up a little bit
tracks with the surface moves over so
that's a good one because that one kept
me above the surface but if you watch
this next one once we get done
take one more cut
well it's backpacks this is a case where
I'm actually ending up hard to see there
but I am going up below the surface so
the machine had to pull up and get over
it
so there I may want to use a little
larger retrack strategy before I did
that that tracking move so instead of
just the 10 mil up maybe I want to go
100 mil up 50 mil okay all right so that
that should start to give you guys a
little bit of the flavor and kind of get
your head a little bit around how this
starts to method eyes from a g-code
perspective but the next thing we want
to really look at is CAD cam based
programs right so what would I expect
and what are some of the challenges when
I start to get into externally posted
programs using this type of cycle so
we're going to start to look at some CAD
cam output a little bit we have a this
example method ice coming out of a cake
game system in I'm going to show you
some of the challenges and some of the
little hurdles you can kind of get
around to maybe make this a little
easier for you so first things first our
cycle 800 is a complex cycle there's a
lot of stuff going on the CAD cam
systems don't have to to certainly take
advantage of all this functionality
that's at the psyche level but a lot of
times you know these guys they're not
seem as experts they have to write posts
for all sorts of controls so we kind of
give them a little bit of slack here and
there especially when you get to it's a
complex cycle like this so when you when
you get your post when you get your
output what I always like to do as a
testing method for any can cycle that's
been posted externally is I like to open
up the cycle and one of the first things
you can see here is if there's a problem
with the cycle the mask should give you
some kind of an alarm so in this case
the post builder was trying to use and
access by a solution that's being driven
by this type 57 here but he didn't set
up properly the direction option because
he didn't even realize he had to support
it so the system tells me how did I ran
this without opening up I probably would
have gotten alarmed when I went
physically run the part
so this is a quick simple easy way to
check any canned cycle high speed cycle
8:32 drug links to any of the can cycles
if you want to check first thing I was
do open them up and take a look at the
mask and see if the cycle thinks it's
okay now the number certainly could be
wrong it's not going to know that but if
there's if there's setup issues in the
cycle will catch that right here now
where do I go to figure out what all
these index is what all these places are
see it's real easy we have control right
you have the luxury of opening up this
data masks and even externally within
Cindi train like you're seeing I have
that option but what if I'm writing the
cycle from km system in a post and I
don't have the luxury of having a
Siemens control in front of me well
you're going to want to go to our
support website so it's support industry
team is calm and in here you can get to
all sorts of documentation but the the
Bible and my humble opinion is what we
call our job planning manual so come to
the sport Network the Siemens industry
support network type in job planning
it'll do a search it will come up with
this PDF download it and save it inside
of the job planning manual there is a
chapter chapter 19 you see right here in
the list called programming cycles
externally and what it does is it breaks
down every cycle within control cycle
800 included and talks about each
variable and what they are so if I
wanted to know what the eighth place
over meant right that would be counting
it out between commas 1 2 3 all the way
to 8 here it'll tell me that's the
rotation rotation axis to the settings
now it's a little cryptic so it's
referring to a mode so our underscore
mode function I would have to look to
see ok well what is option for setup for
one two three four that goes back to let
me go back to a program the type 77
right one two three four so what it's
saying is depending on what setting I'm
in in in mode will depend on the
functionality of this parameter it's
dependent on that right if I'm in it if
I'm in a access by axis type 57 well
then I'm not going to use a direct axis
position here right there's a location
of coordinate rotation so you'll have to
get your head around it a little bit but
it is priceless when you're trying to
dig into these cycles and figure out
what each of these variables means now
the other thing that we get a lot of
guys question about is the number of
commas and you know a lot of guys maybe
think oh the builders manipulating this
because there's more common than one
machine and the next machine the way
this really works is we are always
trying to strive for our programs to
being upwards compatible or our cycles
so that means if we want to add
functionality to a can cycle like cycle
a 100 what we do is we just add a few
more options to the end of the cycle
string more commas so if you see that
one machine has a cycle with more commas
than the other it's probably just
running newer software because that's
how it works
now if you method eyes a cycle for older
software it should certainly still work
in the newer software so if you build
your cycle a hundred with 14 commas and
the latest ones up to 16 and that was a
fully functioning cycle 100 from a
g-code perspective it's still at work
fine now there may be some new features
you want to take advantage of keeping
your output code up-to-date with our
cycle functions that's why you would
start to look at these common places and
could implement them from there ok so
one of the other things and actually let
me go back here first second is and this
is always a pain point for anybody
posting externally is this swivel data
name
now the Swivl down a name that's the GC
one that I kept choosing in our cycle
mask that name is builder definable and
in fact every OEM changes the name I
have some MS that use multiple names
within the same series of machines so
there's no consistency here when you're
writing a post and your method isin
psych 100 what this name is going to be
so there's a couple of things you could
do is from the post development side
what are the first things that I don't
necessarily recommend it but we're
saying saving it right here that if you
don't have any value between the two
quotations and the machine has only one
swivel data record then that is a viable
solution it will only call up the first
record the problem is you're probably
not going to know how many swivel data
records this machine was commissioned
for so if you leave it and you make it
your standard practice to leave the name
this swivel data name always blank here
well that's probably not going to work
on every machine and more likely than
not it's not going to work so one of the
things that I use sometimes that I find
pretty helpful is you can set up a
variable inside the the name of the
record now the name since it's a name is
a string so string defines basically
anything that can be used numerically
and have letters in it so it's some form
of a name now it could be numbers here
so for you to replace the quote and the
name with something else all right down
here we have the tc1 what you do is you
have to define - string so defining a
string it's as simple as giving you the
definition statement typing the word
string and then in brackets telling it
how many places how large the string
could physically be end up being so I
just gave it ten places then from there
you're going to give it some variable
names so space in a variable name so I
called it underscore swivel does not
have to start with an underscore but you
want to be very careful to not duplicate
one of our system variables here so I
like to always use an underscore first
because we don't use underscores for
system variables then I'm going to set
the string that I just created the
string variable so underscore swivel I'm
going to set it equal to in this name so
now I only have to change it in one spot
so if I get the wrong name and the the
user has to make an editing change he
won't have to do it in 30 cycle 800 he
can just make the change right here in
the header and then down in my cycle
mask instead of having quotes in a name
I'm going to write whatever my string
variable is so in this case underscore
swivel this is certainly a very viable
solution however our cycle mask doesn't
like it so the only thing that this is
going to do is if a user then wants to
come in and edit the cycle 800 locally
at the control he will have to select
the other one so just because the
exception I hear this doesn't mean that
this wouldn't run this actually will run
so if I showed you a program here this
is that program I'm talking about so
here I define this string of swivel and
then inside swivel cycle I called it
swivel so if I was to simulate this real
quick here you see it's not going to
give me any errors or any alarms it's
happy but from the controls perspective
everything's good so we'll just speed it
up whatever there we go
okay but if I open up the data mask it
is going to yell at me it's because a
this this record name doesn't exist so
if you want to do any dating at the
control you are going to then have to
just toggle it to the appropriate name
hit accept and then it will build from
there but outside of that this is a nice
solution if you well come up with
something a little bit more universal
from a post perspective when handling
cycle strings like this okay
so from here I did want to give you guys
a chance to see this part method eyes
out of a typical cad/cam system in this
case I happen to use NF camp
so just model the basically I took the
same model part that I had made the
print from brought it into NX laid
coupled options of toolpath onto it so
just like we did before long hand I did
three different facing strategies and
then came in and milled out a little
helical hole drilled some holes and then
put my chain frame so I met that like
the part hosted it out through a post
that was obviously native to NX and then
got my tool path here so so we can go
and actually take a look at this and
then we can run it for you real quick so
you can get it just get it get your own
is around it so when we start to look at
output tool path I mean every post
developer can do it a little different
ways but this is pretty common from what
you would see so you're going to see
some some comments obviously defining
some specifics about maybe the print
that was used whatever date and time you
may see some variable just definitions
so this post happens to like to use the
variable underscore cam tolerance in
cycle inside of cycle 8:32 so they're
defining a real a real or an integer
would be a numerical value or real
supports decimal places integer would be
a whole number then we're going to do
that same method that we talked about
earlier you want to send the machine to
a safe location with the tool carrier
enabled then from there cancel the
offset do your standard safety line if
the post is supporting the blank great
you can post it here if it's not I want
to make sure certainly that I have a
clamping there I can insert this
manually then we have comments here you
see where they're setting the camp
tolerance and then later when they use
it
there's an example of them using the
Segway 32 which is our high speed
function but when we get down to the
swivel cycle record you see it looks
like just like we did on arms so we can
start to drive down this is doing some
toolpaths
they're canceling their cycle 800 here
they did with the open close parenthesis
now this is a little bit of a mix
because remember we was talking about
kinematic independent this happens to
have some rotary axis called out at
least in the retract strategy so how do
I move this to a different machine this
would have to be updated but what's nice
is it's only this I wouldn't have to go
into all the cycle in hundreds and
update them they would work on either
types of machine kinematic BC or mix
kinematic then we're going to go and
orient on r45 so that he decided to use
again axis axes strategy in this post
and away we go
so the resulting tool path is going to
look basically the same as you saw it'll
be slightly different obviously because
the CAD cam system is up let me slow
this down I'll rerun it for you and
we'll do a little show tool path here
alright
so here's our cutting it they're doing a
little bit more optimized based on the
surface but I intentionally obviously
method eyes this thing so it would look
like the part program we long handed or
the example we went through here then
there we go so that's really what you'll
start to expect to see start to expect
to see method eyes one of the things you
will see a lot more from a posted
perspective there's a lot more redundant
commands and redundant structure a lot
of times it just makes it easier when
you're developing the posts don't be
surprised about seeing you know maybe a
a feature being set multiplies over the
same value a lot of times it's not
enough logic there and the post to say
well it was said earlier I know it's
modal so you do get a little bit more
redundancy in an output program but
you'll see that the structures will look
the same as we did now certainly the
tool pathing not common to see CAD cam
systems using our milling cycles but
absolutely from the drilling perspective
so if I go down here and I got to where
we drill some holes right there there's
our cycle 83 so if I wanted to check
this drilling cycle and trust me if you
did when I first played around with this
post first thing I did was open it up
and make sure then the numbers seemed
legit now the values look a little weird
because from a CAD cam perspective
they're going in and they're leaving the
zero wherever the global part zero is so
when she tips up on some kind of an
angle right when it rotates back now the
cam system just compensated because it's
never shifting like we did it's never
shifted zero here it's only doing a
rotational value
so that's why the numbers might look a
little strange because the zero stay
where it is the orientation of the Z
plant name is following and the play is
being set up just on that surface okay
so the only other thing that I did want
to touch real quick is when we start to
run an auto mode just a couple features
that I find really helpful especially
when you get the five axis mid program
start we've gone through this a bunch in
other webinars a lot of you guys have
had any exposure to our control are
familiar with being able to start a
program anywhere within the program and
if you use with calculations it'll scan
to that point set up modal's it'll set
up all rotations everything that
occurred prior to it but the other thing
that's very handy when you get the five
axis is this over storm mode so this is
kind of like having MDI in the middle of
auto mode so at any point when I'm
running let's say for argument's sake we
are running this part we'll just get or
moving a little bit so let's say my
speed was wrong or I needed to move out
and kind of get out of my position so
all I have to do is hit a cycle stop and
my over store button becomes active now
I can come into over store and I can
treat this like a little MDI
so maybe I want to send my Z to I don't
know 100 cycle start and the machine
will move to that location I could have
turned coolant on I could change the
feed rate whatever I want to do then
once I back out of them bode hit cycle
start it's going to reposition back at
the point I which I stopped to that and
then continue moving this is very handy
when I have spindles especially I can
rotate because I could be down inside a
hole I could be normal to that holes now
for me to pull out of that hole I now
have to move at some vector I have to
move a coaxial simultaneously so for me
I just did a simple Z but it could have
been moving three axes at a time
you're going to do that also as long as
you don't shut the program down the
offsets just active so I could go back
and jog the machine if I wanted to and
worst case scenario if I killed it in
the middle of a rotation I was down
inside of a hole I can also go back to
my jog swivel screen and set with this
set zero plane a temporary zero
establishing whatever offsets are here
as a zero plane and then I move a Z
normal that using that little WCS MCS
trick I showed you so those are just a
couple things that you may not have
played around with from the three axis
world that become very handy when you're
dealing with five axis technology the
over store is certainly a big one there
okay so with that being said I think
we're at the end of the content yeah
here this was just showing you how you
can move your zero anywhere on the part
and the system will will run that but
what I'd like to do is we went through a
lot of material certainly would like to
open it up to questions so we have the
chat window or the Q&A Q&A probably a
little easier for me so if you guys have
some questions specifically on the
content or any content feel free to to
type them in or ask okay now we covered
a lot of material here all right so it
looks like we have a question what do I
know here is is cine train readily
available to people like us absolutely
so what we have for cine train and just
to show you real quick I'm just going to
go to Google here one of the quickest
and easiest ways to get a copy of Sydney
train is if you go to our C & C for you
website so what you want to do let me
see if the internet is going to want to
run in here if you want to go to our
Siemens seems to for you and what you
can do is you can request a copy and the
if you don't have a full license what it
will do is it'll run in trial mode and
the trial mode will basically allow you
to manipulate the machines around the
only thing it doesn't let you do is just
bring programs in and out if you want to
then use it for a tool or maybe your
debugging code stuff like that then you
can get a full version certainly we
quote that to you but the trial version
works out great for just kind of getting
your head around moving the machine
around playing with some toolpath stuff
like that so C and C the number for the
word y-o-u if you just do a quick search
for that you're just going to pop up and
you're looking for the URL that has
industry that USA in it this is going to
drive you right to our landing page
that's also the same page where you can
go
and you can get access to all the
webinar content once you get there there
is an option you're going to hunt around
for here that allows us to request a
copy of sinew training I don't want to
waste a lot of time here for you but it
is on this website if you can't find the
link shoot me an email and I'd be happy
to get you the direct link right to it
but you can certainly request a copy
would you align an edge before a plane
and would it then follow the plane align
so and then we did talk about that so so
no you never want to align the edge
first because it doesn't know based on
that orientation when you go to the
align plane so always do the plane first
once you've aligned the plane then you
can present the edge because now once
you've aligned the plane that edge
should be perpendicular to the plane and
then you find it same thing with finding
a bore right if my bore wasn't
perpendicular to my my probe I wouldn't
want to go in and find the bore and then
make the probe that bore perpendicular
so on the align the plane first great
question Mike thank you is there a way
to update my sinew train so there is
again I can get you the link you can
come into here or the other one I
actually like to go to a lot is our
German counterpart site because that
also has cine train that you can
download on our site right now if you
request it we'll send you out a copy of
it if you go to our German colleagues
you can actually download directly it is
quite large now one thing you want to
pay attention to do with updating cine
train is what version um you currently
have what your license version is so if
you have a version 4.5 license that will
support all the way up to version 4.5
edition 3 that was the version we were
just running if you have if you want to
get into version 4.7 which are latest
version it would require a new license
so from there then you would have to
purchase a new license again so it would
depend obviously based on what version
you have but
do have a bunch of different versions
for given licenses okay we see if I
does the align edge with coordinate
rotate then stack onto the found values
for the pull from the plane okay so this
is where you want to be want to be a
little bit careful not often not always
so so what the question is is if we were
to come in to jog to find an aligned
plane these using
oh no no I'm sorry I'm just read it so
this is the line edge with coordinate
rotation then stack onto the values of
line plane yes it does so as long as
you're using coordinate rotation sorry
about that I misread it real quick and
that's back here this coordinate
radiation of rotary axes if I'm using
the align plane the coordinate rotation
is just going to write to the other
coordinate of those three axes so that's
really what should have to do when using
the viola plane in relation to the align
edge function if you use the direct axis
function then you're going to start to
get offsets
found in both the direct axis position
as well as or no rotation and that's
where you can run into trouble ok how
can we activate the simulation in the
program thanks I'm not sure if I fallout
activate the simulation program section
so the machine itself should be
commissioned to support it if I'm
following a correct so oh I guess my
first question is do you have the
simulation button visible here
simulation isn't an option it's a
standard feature I have seen some
builders especially on real advanced
machines may not support the simulation
function or want to support it
based on their crazy kind of kata
kinematics so they may have inhibited it
but if not you should be able to
activate it now as far as if you're
going in the simulation and yet seeing
the blank well that's probably because
the g-code program just didn't have the
workpiece blank to find it so you can
manually enter the blank like I did when
I wrote the program just simply by going
to various going to blank and inserting
it here additionally if you go into
simulation and the blank is not there it
will start just moving the tool around
and you can actually go into show path
and see it but you also get let me shut
it off here a blank button so if you
don't want to add the blank to the part
program let's say for argument's sake
the programs are locked and you can't
edit them but you want to get this the
3d graphics up
come into the physical blank button and
it looks the same as the cycle it's just
not going to act physically insert it
into the part program it's just going to
set up the block there for you whatever
the dimensions so mind see how it
changed because I had some other numbers
there all right
so the key is not available okay this is
back to the stimulation question so if
the key is not available the OEM is
probably inhibiting it so what you not
to do is you'd want to go back to your
OEM to find out why they're not allowing
it to be activated they may have some
other reasoning from their end because
normally that button should always be
there what is the best pathology to
machine parts that may not be aligned
with a machine axis so if the physical
part program itself is aligned to the
axis but the actual part is not well
that's what we're going to use those
rotational commands like we talked about
so that's the beauty of them the part
can be oriented anywhere if the g-code
program thought it was aligned to X but
you have a rotation about z at the work
corner level the machine will do all the
competition for you so really that's
where it comes into play now certainly
if the toolpath was compensated ready to
be at some compound angle then you're
going to have to state relative to that
because that's what she's going to do
right so if the actual g-code program is
doing x and y motion to be parallel to a
surface you'd have to mimic that but as
long as the part program thinks it's
straight you can align that thing
anywhere you want on space any
rotational value any plane and as long
as the were coordinate values have the
rotations it's going to follow that
orientation
so this was working with seizure for 782
and the keys a grey color
ah this may be the little password level
that you're into regarding your
simulation question so just for
argument's sake go to menu select go to
setup and set the machine to the
manufacturer level it's probably sitting
at level zero so what you want to do
there is you want to go in you want to
hit password set password it's all caps
type the word sunrise sunrise is going
to put you to machine level and then
you're going to go from there okay great
let me see jump back to the window how
can I make sure that simulation matches
my machine I'm assuming we're probably
talking about from the Stinney training
perspective of the software we're in
here so one nice thing that Cindy
trained does is it allows me to build a
virtual machine from the physical
machine archive of my machine so I can
actually have and I'll show you guys
here real quick I have a whole library
of different machines that I've built so
see all these machines here well some of
them were generic but some of them you
see here's a dmg here's a smithing
machine here's a tool Mac machine
there's a roaming machine there's a
Nemco these I built from archive files
so if you guys guys have seen you train
and you have a machine on your floor and
you want to have one you do need an
extra license to build this but if you
like you're more than welcome to email
me over your archive and I'd be happy to
build it for you and then you can just
import it now you do need the full
version of cine train to be able to
import
externally created machines but outside
of that if you if you need me to build
you a virtual machine for your senior
train that matches your visible machine
just create archive email out the
archive archives usually aren't more
than four or five megabytes simplest way
to create an archive put a USB stick in
machine and do a control
alternate s if you're on an 8:40 machine
or control alternate see if you're on an
8:28 and a lot of negative dumping
archives to the USB stick keys ask can
you use a model for the blank no
unfortunately not as of yet he also
mentioned with a casting so what I do in
those cases is I just make sure my
primitive blob my primitive blank is
just greater than whatever the part rate
would be and I would understand that
there would be heavier cutting we're
adding more that functionality probably
I haven't seen any of this yet but
hopefully we're going to start to see
this in the not-too-distant future not
only that but we're starting to add more
capability of adding the workholding
into like the machine space model and
the collision avoidance so hopefully
that's coming down down the road okay so
there was a question is it possible to
download the presentation I don't post
them but they're certainly available if
anybody would like to get your hands on
it just shoot me an email and I'd be
happy to send it to you I'll put up my
info again here real quick
you guys had it from before so if you
just shoot me an email to Christophe
Pollak at Siemens comm I'd be happy to
share any of that information with you
guys okay great well thank you for all
the great questions hopefully I didn't
miss any if I did always feel free to
reach out to me I'm going to stop the
recording now